foreign
[Music]
Khan and welcome to the future of work
explained in this short documentary
we'll talk to some incredible experts
from across the world and learn about
the future of work now the future of
work is something that's constantly
evolving and a lot of different things
are impacting the future of work some of
these are technology Technologies such
as automation robotics industry 4.0 all
of these have an impact on the work we
do many jobs are being outsourced many
jobs are automated and people are
changing jobs as a result of that
there's a constant augmentation of the
workforce which means we are seeing
different roles evolve and many roles
phase out with time how does that impact
what we do for work and how does that
impact the workforce around the world in
different industries from accounting to
Manufacturing in different Industries
such as space exploration or medical
Sciences every job is changing a little
bit every single day in this documentary
I present you perspectives that I
gathered by speaking with these experts
from everywhere and across the board we
have representation from the Consulting
side of the industry from manufacturing
and many others
first of all I'd like to say that as we
go forward from an era that covid-19 has
created and as we head into a time where
a significant change in work has taken
place we should recognize that having
skills and changing skills and acquiring
new skills should be a big part of what
we do you'll hear some of these things
in the conversations that I'll present
to you in the next few minutes but
please take this doc please take this
documentary as a dipping off the toes
into something that's constantly
evolving if you open the news you hear
about the metaverse and many other
technologies that are going to change
the world and they will the next 5 10 15
20 years in our lifetime are going to
radically and dramatically change the
way we do things and the reason for this
is that change is a constant change has
always happened and it'll continue to
happen so we shouldn't really be
surprised if things change around us and
what is in our control is to change
ourselves and to acquire skills that are
used and can be used in the future
without further Ado let's look at these
conversations and see who's up first
when I reflect back on the last 12 to 18
months we have seen massive change with
respect to the nature of work and
Consulting and the good news is that
they sit here today I'm so optimistic
about the future and that's because I
think our profession has demonstrated
amazing resilience over the last
12 18 months if you and I had had this
conversation a year ago
I think we would have had legitimate
questions about how do you move
a profession that is largely in person
sitting side by side with their teams
and their clients each and every day to
a hundred percent virtual by way of
delivery of the services
hiring under team members onboarding of
new team members and the development of
our teams I think just like the rest of
the economy manufacturing has changed
dramatically because of the pandemic I
think it's how we work uh majority
manufacturers stayed open throughout the
height of closures and and when the
economy kind of came through a pause in
the spring of 2020. most manufacturers
remained open because of course they
were part of this essential response and
not only the consumer goods we needed
the PPE all of the other protective
equipment but everything we need to live
our lives and so manufacturing remained
open but how we worked was different so
of course production teams needed to be
on the floor but those who could be
remote companies made a really concerted
effort to use new technology to allow
some of their Workforce to be remote so
that they were able to keep those who
had to be in on the production floor
safe and so I think the adoption of
Technology of remote work really
accelerated in manufacturing just like
it did throughout most of the economy
one of our biggest challenges in the
sector is this Antiquated idea of
manufacturing I think people have this
you know we go out and do research on
this and and we people have this idea of
like it's a b-roll from the 50s 60s 70s
whatever your generation is what seemed
like old old movie b-rolled suit in your
mind and that it was very manual and
Manufacturing is hardly that anymore
today and it is very automated it has a
lot of technology and it has people
working alongside the technology the
automation that has come on to make us
be more productive that replaces tasks
not jobs and that is what has has truly
I think accelerated in the last several
years covid was interesting we weren't
sure at the beginning if if projects
with more automation was going to be
invested in because of covid because the
physical distancing and yet what we
found is projects that were already
online continue to Pace I think the
onboarding of new technology is a
tremendous benefit to our Older Workers
are more mature and skilled workers
let's face it it's going to allow people
to stay in the workforce longer I have
tons of stories and examples of
companies that have brought on new
technology that's allowed an older
worker to be able to continue in their
job because now they're operating the
Machinery not actually doing doing
something themselves Older Workers are
able to then Engage The Millennials and
the Gen Z's with some of the ways that
things are done the unwritten rules the
things that you learn just through
experience and that is strengthening so
we've seen through our research at the
manufacturing Institute is that workers
are actually able to stay longer because
of the new technologies and companies
are constantly you know education is is
not a destination it is an ongoing
process in careers today particularly in
manufacturing our technology is evolving
annually every year there's new things
coming on new ways to do things that are
faster better you know stronger but also
more efficient so that we can keep
production here you know we always had
this mentality of you know I want this
person as a direct report to me to be at
headquarters so that I can see them I
can be with them every day I've
fundamentally changed my opinion about
that having you have to go to an office
eight to five every day seven you know
five days a week I think those days are
long gone the idea of the sort of
40-hour
uh five-day work week with the two-day
weekend it's such an old concept you
know the Genesis of that has so much to
do with you know our lives and the
agricultural world has some religious
connotations uh there's a whole range of
reasons that in a very diverse and uh
world and Progressive world are are
probably not that relevant anymore well
to me the last one and a half years is
an acceleration of a trend that was
really already going on going back to
maybe 2008
which was the digitization of work the
use of AI and software and mobile apps
in video and social networking but then
the pandemic pretty much taught us that
the title stuff is much much more
powerful than we realized and that
people can re can work in any location
and be very very productive probably for
the first 30 to 60 days many companies
were paralyzed and then we realized that
this pandemic was going to last longer
than originally thought and so people
started looking at the white space and
understanding what can we really do
differently probably the first thing
that happened was the Embrace of
Technology the companies that were
Farther Along their technology road map
were the first to start moving again and
by that I mean they had teams in place
they had zoom in place they had Miro
they had other tools that allowed their
workers
and vendors to work collaboratively
through technology we first look at the
past we look at what the future of work
was in the past and how work was done in
the past we're not going to go too deep
into history but getting some
perspective on how things were done will
really help move forward
I've spent the last year and a half
finding the best talent I could find
wherever they live and hire them
wherever they are and I think many
companies I think smart CEOs are going
to take that same approach there are
many technologies that are out there
today that are ways that teams can spend
time together and interact with teams
and share content with each other in a
meaningful way
one of the things that I think has
shifted most dramatically is the use of
video conferencing and so we and our
clients have the capability to use it at
this level for a significant period of
time but in many companies it just
wasn't anymore
whereas today it is much more than
normal and I think what we're finding is
that through the
capabilities we actually can collaborate
together really well and so that that
means we've got more choices with
respect to when we need to be in person
and when we can be virtual which I think
is wonderful the nature of work is
changing Americans for example North
Americans are increasingly freelancing
right they're not they're not even part
of an organization the data is quite
remarkable it's now in the 35 almost 40
percent of Americans are freelancing so
work is always evolved let's recognize
that this is the idea that a job that
you were doing today might not be
relevant to five years it is not
necessarily A New Concept what we can't
say though is the frequency and the
velocity
by which the workforce is changing is
different than it was in previous
generations of previous centuries what
is the biggest risk to Enterprises today
my answer is sometimes surprising my
answer is relevancy you know because the
the ability for that some startup to
enter your space
effectively destroy your business in a
short amount of time it's higher than
it's ever been so you got to be
continuing to reinvent and rethink I
think work is no longer a place
it's a thing you do and sometimes
there's a place involved sometimes
there's not a place involves and I think
that's now become very clear to every
company you know one of the big changes
Ian that I've seen in the workforce in
my career and I'm in my mid-60s is if
you go back to you know the 70s and the
80s work was all about conforming
you're going to be like everybody else
and the more you can be like everybody
else the better you're going to perform
in your career because the company is
expecting Conformity we talk about the
future of work but I really think it's
the now of work
now the theme is radical flexibility not
only where work gets done but how it
gets done and by whom and I mean that
companies now are really rethinking
their human capital Supply chains and
bringing strategies that are much more
agile and flexible and based upon skills
needed versus full-time equivalent roles
there's a a saying that baby boomers
used to fit life into work and today
it's the opposite today we fit work into
life we had some employees that lived
out of an RV and and worked from
national parks they could because they
have the talent set that was so in
demand they knew they could stay busy as
long as they could find Wi-Fi that's a
completely different Paradigm than 30
years ago when an employer would have
offered a job would have been in one
specific location and would have had
required hours that just doesn't happen
today 40 of the workforce is thinking
about quitting their jobs okay every
employer is going to have to deal with
that reality the talent has learned
through the pandemic that they want
different things from the employer
employee relationship so thinking about
how we build work that is that is
productive that's meaningful for people
and rewarding I think is where we should
be focusing our our efforts in terms of
what's our vision for the future of work
and then what do we need to do to bring
that to life work is a very human
endeavor and work is shaped by humans
right it's sort of our choices what are
the what are the incentives and Norms we
have around work what are our
expectations and how do we
um how do we shape business policies
public policies
um and our in our own practices it's
going to be a while before people feel
like it's the normal is to go to the
office instead of stay home I adamantly
believe that technology amplifies human
nature you hear stories of people that
are on Zoom meetings from six in the
morning till eight o'clock at night well
that's a choice that they've made and so
Zoom I.E technology in this case is just
amplifying their own behaviors and so I
think we'll actually get greater
transparency into the behaviors of our
Workforce now let's look at the present
look let's look at the current times
where we live times that are shaped by
Massive change across the world whether
it's social economic reasons whether
it's the pandemic or Wars that are
taking place whether it's social unrest
or changes that emerging technology is
bringing the present is constantly
changing let's look at some of the
comments on the present I think thinking
too short term you know nothing's going
to change that quickly in the next year
or two or three look you know these
Trends are are happening over I would I
would say we'll see the significant
changes in sort of more the decade time
Horizon and Beyond there's no doubt that
remote working is here to stay
working from home or
wfx working for from anywhere is sort of
a new mantra the cost of working has
been enormous to Mental Health
of course physical health still a lot of
danger to a lot of jobs
people aren't satisfied people aren't
happy a lot so you know how we design
and deliver working really does
ultimately reflect
on whether we are happier as humans in
99 of employees want to do the right
thing they want to be successful they
want to get promoted they want to get a
raise they want to help their peers so
just because somebody maybe couldn't
come into the office or is working at
home for their own choice doesn't mean
they're not doing the job you know we're
in a very tight labor market and it's
getting worse so it isn't really so much
of a choice anymore it's really a
decision of how much flexibility you
want to offer people and if you do it in
a trusted way where the employees feel
that they are trusted and not monitored
and micro
um you know they'll they'll abide by the
policies and usually do a great job so
how do we think about different
structures
um that would encourage companies to
engage people in the work it's something
technology companies use regularly right
they have
um you know ways that they give people
equity in the in the firm and that sort
of thing so so can we think about
different ways to sort of expand that so
that they're sort of more of a shared
stake in the success of of different
kinds of Enterprises but I do see a
trend of people trying to take less of a
atomized view of work and more of a
holistic view of sort of how do we
design work for people again and and not
think of people and robots as being the
same I I thought this
change that we have gone through would
have happened many years ago because the
inefficiencies of going to an airport
and climbing on a plane and all the time
lost getting from to and from places to
commute time
it can be so much more productive with
all of the technology that exists and
and is ever changing now one issue that
I see for the future is how do you deal
with balancing
isolation and yet keeping and engaged
and productive Workforce Innovations are
also accelerating and when Innovations
converge and have societal impact that
progress is deflationary that's why we
all walk around the billion dollar
computers in our pockets today called
smartphones what some people are
referring to is return to work is
actually going to be more difficult
than the abrupt chains that we all faced
when we left work to go to our virtual
State the shift in March we all had no
choice it was sort of like abandoned
ship you you had to get into the life
rafts you had to go home and you had to
figure out how to work from home and we
all did that this is different
now we're all coming back voluntarily
and and each person is going to have
different views on what they are willing
to do in this volunteer world coming
back challenges
there are countless challenges when it
comes to the future of work we have to
observe and record and see what are
these challenges and how can we overcome
them every industry has some challenges
some Industries have challenges of not
being able to attract the right Talent
some have the challenge of not being
able to produce goods and Equipment some
have other challenges such as not being
able to grow let's look at some of the
challenges that we face right now
because of the changes to the future of
work so if we work three to five years
from now we will have experienced uh
greater advancements in artificial
intelligence and machine learning
advancements in Edge Computing
5G networks having sensors everywhere
and so while I think that we will
reflect on the massive amount of change
that happened in the last year and a
half I think it's just the beginning of
this rapid base of change in how a
technology changes how we all live in
sort of the Decades ahead of us
I think we're going to see uh
significantly more Freelancers if we're
at 40 now could we see 60 percent of the
workforce being in uh in the sort of
freelance economy
it's possible for a long time now you've
become clear that people are having
several different types of jobs what
we're now going to see are people that
you know may have been a lawyer until
they were 28 and then at 29 they become
a software engineer you know and maybe
uh By the time they're in their 40s they
decide to be an actor perhaps so this
idea that will have multiple jobs is
going to be much more common so your job
may be going away or you could feel that
it's in less demand and you could feel
at risk so if you are looking at that
thing that excites you that next
interesting job yeah be learning form be
learning what what kind of jobs will be
opened up as a result of maybe
cryptocurrencies or or blockchain right
what kind of jobs will be required in
the world of increasing use of
artificial intelligence yeah AI is going
to displace workers but it's also going
to create work so basically what we now
know is that automation creates jobs it
eliminates some work but it creates new
opportunities new roles higher value
work so we don't need to be worried
about the robots taking jobs away from
us the future of work is much more of us
using machines in new ways giving up the
more routine approaches to you to many
many things and just taking advantage of
the technology that's available so one
of the things that's going on in the
future of work is accommodating the
individuality of each worker and finding
ways to embrace that and support that
despite the fact that the work has to
get done and the company has to move
ahead I believe it's a balance that we
need going forward we'll have great
tools to enable our work but we still
need human connection we still need
collaboration we still need to bring
judgment and empathy to the work we do I
think to create the best Solutions
moving forward I mean in our
organization we talk about building what
we call the power of human competencies
which are things like creativity radical
listening
um communication
empathy all of those talents are things
that will become more and more important
as we need to work together as humans in
concert with the technology that enables
our job we know that the manufacturing
companies are investing in their workers
and doing so because they know that when
they have a higher skilled job that they
need to fill their best applicants are
going to be their own Workforce If they
raise up through new upskilling and so I
think we need to have a mind shift it's
no longer you have one job your whole
career even if you stay with one company
is that you're continually evolving
through education through upskilling and
and the sky's the limit so I think
skills will become even more essential
than just having people you need people
with the right skills and we need to
change our mindset around that and I
think what we'll see is more Innovation
and more excitement what I see today
coming to life for the future using AR
and VR as a daily occurrence not a video
game it is actually part of your job and
that I think is going to be really
exciting to this next Generation coming
up I'm gonna hope we'll be one of those
people that tries to stay in an
environment where we kind of have a
remote first mentality
and and it has a lot to do with hiring
the best talent and using Technologies
like zoom in order to optimize you know
the interactions with people not having
to show up in an office and then
building a model where we will have
shared workspace where needed in cities
where we have a few people that can work
together teams that need to spend time
together now that there's greater
comfort with using remote workers I
think we will see a normalization or
maybe a harmonization of global wage
scales for certain white-collar work I'm
going to say we're out of the woods as
it relates to significant pandemic
exposure well beyond just covid-19 but
other pandemics Etc in two years you
could probably see a much greater return
to the work to the cities and to the
office buildings those companies that
decide to harness the power of knowledge
that exists beyond what they thought of
as their four traditional walls that's
who's going to win you're seeing it in
the tech companies some of the greatest
Innovations on the planet are coming
from open source technology if you can
work remotely you can work as a digital
Nomad provided to technological
infrastructures capable of supporting
connectivity right
so I do think that in terms of the
worker choosing
where they want to work if it's a remote
job function they will be able to do
that I also believe that governments
will make sure that they get their piece
of tax revenue and so we're just on the
front end of how will various
governments tax digital Nomad economic
flows in the next two to five years I
think there's literally going to be a
war for talent the first thing I would
say is to understand that not only
change is going to be forever but the
pace of change is increasing I believe
that what people really need to
understand about change is it is going
to not only be Perpetual but the rate of
change is going to increase the future
they say is already here
foresight experts and futurists talk
about many things that emerging
technology will change social and
political changes will change and how we
can shape the future to foresight now
the future is also something we can act
towards by proactively doing things that
can help us get where we need to be in
the future here are some of the
observations that are esteemed list of
gas tabs when it comes to the future if
you don't have an abundance of curiosity
and a willingness to dig in and learn
you're not going to be able to keep that
step ahead that you need to be able to
keep if we're going to work from
anywhere or even you know even at
minimum work from home we have to have
good connectivity you know the emergence
of fifth generation of cellular which is
really a game changer uh once that is
deployed in
a saturated way in our Urban environment
our flexibility of where we work and how
we work and what we work on is going to
change what we do is changing technology
is shaping The Human Experience right we
want more digitalization we want more uh
online access to services and products
we want them delivered uh and so we we
are encouraging sort of a delivery
infrastructure which is creating
opportunity and plus you know jobs in
the gig economy of course learning is
essential to business success the most
successful companies are learning all
the time learning how to be better at
what they do today and learning how to
add value in unique ways you're learning
what the customers want next they're
learning about Technologies and how they
can automate and improve business
processes so
if you're not learning as a company
you're probably probably falling behind
you know you can look at Management in
two ways number one get the job done get
hit your numbers and you'll be rewarded
number two take care of the people grow
the people build the people for the rest
of the organization and I think more and
more companies are pushing to the second
where the role of management isn't just
to execute but also to build people's
skills and capabilities so they can be
better capable of doing new things
inside the company those are the
companies that have been around a long
time and last different business Cycles
they've they're learning organizations
you know I'm in my 60s and I have no
problem learning about new technology I
grew up with you know
three PC days
um I think most older people are just as
happy to learn about technology as young
people but they might need a little more
help they didn't grow up with social
networks they didn't grow up with mobile
phones their whole life and they might
be intimidated but they'll pick it up I
think the the real sort of message to
older workers is uh you know number one
take the time to learn about the tools
at work get your Human Resources your
people organization to think more
creatively about the engagement model
with Talent because no longer will every
person delivering value to the
organization be an employee it might be
a freelancer it might be a gig worker
that works for another organization and
receives benefits from that organization
there will be many ways that you build
out your talent fabric
and the people organization of these
companies needs to be ready for that I
would advise young people to really kind
of have a breadth of sort of disciplines
that they're at least have some passing
familiarity with find your certainly
find you're the one that you really like
and dive into that but
um you know I think having sort of this
breadth of vision and not not
pigeonholing yourself too quickly as a
leader I've lived with the notion in
that it you know I I call it you know
you have to let people work when they
either work and be do whatever else they
need to do whenever else they need to do
it and I I've been doing this for years
if you you know when you have kids they
have things they need to do in the
afternoon it's again it's around
achievement that's not when you do it
but the complete should not be achieved
what I'm doing is I'm fractionalizing
what most companies would say is their
most valuable asset which is human
capital
so we're fractionalizing the work day
and the career for the individual worker
and we're fractionalizing the workforce
well beyond the full-time employees for
the Enterprise that fractionalization is
going to drive liquidity into the
hottest skills and capabilities and
they'll be market price so my advice
would be in addition to trying to make
sure you have the model right is really
working through the rank and file of the
organization to make sure that there is
buy-in that there's acceptance and that
there is the true appreciation for why a
specific model was selected
recommendations
so far we've seen what the past of work
seemed like what the present is what
challenges we face and what the future
looks like here are some recommendations
on what we should be doing what are some
of the things that we should maybe
incorporate in our Industries in our
work in our capacities as leaders and
professionals and maybe create a better
future for work for ourselves in the
future my biggest advice for people
would be to actually follow the lead of
what some of the young people in the
workforce have proven to us their works
and that is be a self-learner what I've
learned from younger workers is don't
wait for the organization to teach you
how technology works there is ample
opportunity to literally really just go
on the internet
and find self-help to be able to learn
how to use technology so take some
responsibility on your own we we often
talk about how young people sort of pick
this up naturally and one of the reasons
they do that is they're not afraid of
going and looking for the answer and
trying to figure it out and I think
those of us in the older generation
could learn a lot from them
Vol as many diverse voices in the change
process as you can where I hope things
are going is a really nice balance for
people so that we've got the human
interaction that we were so used to in
the past coupled with using technology
in order to be able to have the balance
that we talked about we need to build an
infrastructure that allows people to
easily access the internet by the way
we've got to get another few billion
people onto the internet right today the
number is about it's about 60 percent of
the world is connected I think the
numbers uh even maybe uh into the 60s
because we're Connecting People rapidly
but in a world of almost 8 billion
people you know that means there's still
a a few billion people that woke up this
morning and don't have access to all the
benefits of the internet and Hyper
connectivity you know one of the things
I've learned in my career is you know
every day there's something in the
technology environment that's difficult
or doesn't work right if I don't stop
and figure it out later I suffer more so
every each one of us has to take a
little bit of extra time and learn how
to use the tools we have the second
thing is for older people you know
people are living longer so you may feel
like you're the old guy or the old gal
and you know maybe you're fading out
you're probably not you're probably more
essential and more important as a mentor
as a coach as an expert then people may
realize that you may realize and I think
old people need to just you know kind of
have a young attitude about their jobs
and that will make it easier for them to
learn new things and feel comfortable
about some of these intimidating new
technologies that really aren't that
hard to learn once you just roll up your
sleeves and get involved we're going to
be working in different places using
different tools they'll be virtual
reality they'll be voice recognition
they'll be facial recognition we'll be
doing video conferencing we'll have all
sorts of intelligent agents things will
be recommending what to do and what not
to do
um and we need to just be comfortable
with that
um and you don't have to be a software
engineer to be comfortable with tools 90
of the jobs in the economy today are
service jobs we have become a service
economy there are very few highly
routine manual labor jobs left they're
there but there aren't very many of them
and what that means is that employers
are beginning to realize the need to
realize that the way they treat people
and the quality of the work experience
and the quality of the jobs is essential
to their success as a company
you know Southwest Airlines isn't a
great Airline because they buy Great
Planes they're great Airline because
people love working there and as if it's
as an outcome of loving working there
they love the customers and they love
the passengers and therefore they are a
great company that is true in every
single organization I've ever talked to
I think even older workers and I'm a
baby boomer understand
that choices are different today and
even the Baby Boomers don't want to
return to the office nine to five
anymore so we need to bring an attitude
of change we need to embrace that we
need to learn and we need to have a
commitment to learning moving forward I
guess it's the same advice everybody
sort of says is sort of you know learn a
bunch of things and then find the thing
that really really works for you friends
thank you so much for your time I really
really appreciate it I hope this
documentary provided some guidance and
some idea on where we're headed there's
so much more to talk and we've just
barely scratched the surface today I
hope you continue this journey and learn
more about the future of work you can
contact anybody who was in this
documentary or reach out to me and I'll
do the introductions but the future of
work is something we have to work on we
have to create a proactively be a
participant in I wish you all the best
for your organizations your governments
your entities your businesses and your
careers have an amazing future and take
care of yourself
foreign
[Music]